yeah I spent about five years moderating
as an administrator at mines and
basically with this kind of power and
control and unless you've done this job
you don't really I doubt you would
understand the level of power you have
is just a cheap employee you can push a
button and turn someone's account off
and they have no recourse and you know
that and and you can do if you your
emotions are telling you maybe that
violates the rules in this way maybe you
can turn it off and then or you can
upscale it to your supervisor and if
they agree with you you can turn it off
or limit the ideas and see which ideas
and promote certain ideas and demote
other ideas and there's no recourse
you'd never get punished for it it's the
most empowering like intoxicatingly
powerful I don't think humans should
have that level of authority at this
stage I think we need like a crowd
sourced you know Judiciary System in
social media yeah because that power is
absolute when you can control what
people think what what goes into
people's minds that is god-like power
and authority that obviously people are
going to be abusing for their own
personal benefit